عنوان اطول المعارك واشرسها في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا
تعرضت المدينه منذ العام الماضي لمحاولات
اقتحام الروسيه لا سيما من قوه فاغنر
اليوم يبدو ان الساعات والايام المقبله
حبله بالمفاجات التي قد تغير من الخارطه
العسكريه في المدينه
تطور عسكري ياتي بالتزامن مع تلويح قائد
قوات فاجنر بالانسحاب في العاشر من الشهر
الجاري لكن الرجل سرعنا ما غير من موقفه
وتوقع سيطره قريبه لقواته على المدينه
تصريح طباخ بوتين الاخير هو ما تدركه كيف
جيدا اما حديث الانسحاب اعتبرته خدعه
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا مليار
قالت ان موسكو تريد الاستيلاء على المدينه
في وقت الاحتفال بيوم النصر في التاسع من
ماي و
مليار اكدت ان روسيا ماضيه في نقل مقاتل
فاجنر من خط المواجهه الى باخموت
للاستيلاء عليها بحلول يوم النصر الروسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات